مقرره الخاصه
للامم المتحده
وحمايه وهي المعنيه بتعزيز وحمايه الحق في
حريه الراي والتعبير الدكتوره ايرين خان
من دكا حول هذا الموضوع وحول استهداف
الصحفيين ب بهذا الشكل غير المسبوق في هذه
الحرب الاسرائيليه على غزه دكتوره ايرين
اولا ما هو رايك ب
بما جرى من استهداف جديد للصحفيين
استهداف نجل الزميل وائل الدحدوح الصحفي
حمزه
وزميله ايضا مصطفى
ثريا اولا هذه ماسه مروعه جدا
ولكن هنا نتحدث عن جريمه حرب وهذه الجريمه
هي جزء من القدر الهائل من القتل الذي
تقوم به القوات الاسرائيليه والذي يعتبر
اباده جماعيه في خضم هذا الصحفيون يقتلون
والعالم يجب ان يعرف ويدرك ما هي الحقيقه
التي تتجلى هناك والكل يجب ان يعرف ما
الذي يجري للصحفيين طريقه قتل واستهداف
الصحفيين امر مروع بكل معنى الكلمه وهو
امر مفزع
جدا نعم هو امر مروع ومفزع هذا هو الوصف
لما يجري لكن كيف يمكن وضع حد لهذا الامر
المروع وال مفزع ودور الامم المتحده في
هذا
المجال
دكتوره
ايرين مجلس الامن الدولي استخدم الفيتو
لاعا قرار وقف اطلاق النار لذلك من المهم
لكل الدول الاعضاء في مجلس الامن الدولي
ان
تنظر الى ما يجلي الى ما يجري في قطاع غزه
خدمه للمدنيين وسلم والامن الدوليين
قواعد القانون الدولي يجب ان تحترم ولكنها
تنتهك في كل دقيقه وفي كل ثانيه من قبل
قوات الدفاع
الاسرائيلي برايك برايك لماذا يتم استهداف
الصحفيين وما الذي تخشاه اسرائيل فعليا من
من عمل الصحفيين والصحافه في قطاع غزه في
هذه
الحرب الصحفيون يستهدفون لان الصحفيين
يخبرون الحقيقه ولانهم يتيحون هذهه
المعلومات والبيانات لنا في كل ارجاء
العالم ولهذا السبب فان السلطات
الاسرائيليه الان ومن خلال قتل
الصحفيين يحاولون ان يمنعوا وصول
المعلومات الى العالم ويريدون ان يعيق ما
يجري
على الارض وذلك لكي لا يكون هناك
ادله
طيب يعني حتى الان
هل هل ما
زالت او ما يحصل في غزه اليوم هل مازال
يحتاج الى ادله لا ادانه اسرائيل او
لمحاسبه اسرائيل في المحافل
الدوليه انت محق هناك قدر كبير من الادله
موجوده الان ولكن في كل دقيقه يجب ان يعرف
العالم ما يجري لان الامر متعلق بالتضامن
والدعم لشعب غزه عندما نرى ما يجري بالطبع
الراي العام الدولي الان هو منحاز لصالح
الناس في غزه لذلك الصحفيون يقومون بتقديم
المعلومات في الوقت الحقيقي وهذا امر مهم
جدا وهم يضحون بانفسهم وبحياتهم وهذا امر
يستحق والحترام ولكن هنا نتحدث عن
الحكومات كالولايات المتحده والدول الاخرى
والمسؤولون في الامم المتحده يجب ان
يتحركوا ويضعوا ضغوطا على اسرائيل لضمان
القيام بالوصول الى هدنه في اسرع وقت ممكن
اذا كانت الهدنه او وقف اطلاق النار
ممنوع بفيتو داخل مجلس الامن السؤال
المطروح ما هي الوسائل المتاحه لردع
اسرائيل عن
تصرفاتها وجرائمها بحق الصحفيين في
غزه اعتقد ان المسائله امر مهم جدا فكما
تعلمون تم تقديم دعوه لمحكمه العدل
الدوليه من خلال جنوب افريقيا و هناك نظر
في هذه القضيه الان وهذه ادوات مهمه جدا
لكي يكون هناك مسائله لاسرائيل ولكن الراي
العام العالمي امر مهم جدا فنحن كافراد
ومواطنين في العالم يجب ان ندين ما يجري
في غزه
الان يعني الادانه تكون مهمه جدا وهي
موقف يعبر عن ال عما يريده الذي يدين هذه
الاعمال ولكن الا يفترض ان تستتبع الادانه
بفعل حقيقي على الارض باعتبار ان
اسرائيل يعني لا تكترث لمواقف الادانه
والشجب والاستنكار هذا هو واضح حتى
الان طبعا يجب ان يكون هناك تحرك على
الارض
نامل ل هذه الدعوه التي تقدم ان يكون من
شانها وضع ضغوط على اسرائيل وهنا رساله
لبلن ك وزير الخارجيه الامريكي والدول
الاوروبيه ان يكون هناك اجبار وضغط عليهم
لوقف لاطلاق النار فهناك بيانات ومعلومات
تاتي من غزه وهي معلومات مهمه جدا ومن
شانها ان تخلق الراي العام
العالمي للضغط على وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
ان يتوصل الى تسويه ووقف لاطلاق النار و
ايضا هناك تحركات سياسيه يجب ان تقوم بها
الدول كلها الان هل هل
تحملين الدول الداعمه لاسرائيل والرافضه
لوقف اطلاق النار تحملينها مسؤوليه ما
يجري الان في غزه وتحديدا ما يستهدف به
الصحفي بشكل
متعمد بالفعل اي صلاحيات لدينا ومقرر
خاصين وخبراء في الامم المتحده نضع ضغوطا
على الدول وخاصه تلك التي تستخدم حق النقض
الفيتو او تستخدم ايضا حق النقد ضد قرارات
مجلس الامن الدولي والجمعيه
المحده لك نحن نقوم بوض الضغوط عليهم
بالفعل عمليا هل بامكانكم ان تقدموا شيئا
للصحفيين اليوم في
غزه من وجهه نظر عمليه اذا ما قصدت ان كان
لدينا برامج او مساعده انا
كخبير اقول ان الامم المتح
تقدم تقدم المساعدات لغزه ولكن هذا الامر
محدد
ولذلك
فامل
للمساعده ان تصل الى الصحفيين
والمدنيين لكن
بالطبع الامر الاكثر اهميه هو ان يكون
هناك وقف لاطلاق النار طالما القنابل
والقصف يجريان فان الصحفيين لا شك بانهم
سوف يكونون في وع خطير جدا دكتوره ايرين
لطالما اسرائيل تغنت بالديمقراطيه وحريه
الراي والتعبير لديها الان ب نراه على ارض
الواقع في غزه مع استشهاد 109 صحفيين
اخرهم الزميلان مصفى ثريا وحمزه الدحدوح
ما مدى
صدق هذه النظريه التي تحاول اسرائيل
ترويجها بانها
تحترم حريه الراي
والتعبير في الوقت الحاضر وعلى مدى ثلاثه
اشهر فان قتل
الصحفيين امر مازال مستمرا واسرائيل لم
تحترم حقوق الانسان الاساسيه ولا الحق
ب التعبير عن الراي نحن هنا نتحدث عن الحق
بالحياه الصحفيون لهم الحق بان يعيشوا وان
يتحدثوا ويقوم بالتغطيه للحقائق على الارض
نحن نرى اطفالا يقتلون ونساء و اناس مسنين
وهذا يعتبر انتهاكا صارخا للقانون الدولي
الانساني وبالتالي يجب ان تحمل اسرائيل
المسؤوليه عن ذلك الدكتوره ايرين خان من
دكا المقرره الخاصه للامم المتحده المعنيه
بتعزيز وحمايه الحق في حريه الراي
والتعبير شكرا جزيلا لك